Futurama is undoubtedly one of the
greatest sci-fi comedies of all
time — but despite its surprisingly
tight and well thought-out timeline,
the series didn't answer every question it
raised. For example, what became of Bender's son,
Ben? What happens to Fry and Leela after
the time-bending events of the finale?
Is Fry's old girlfriend, Michelle, still going
out with the reanimated body of Pauly Shore?
"'Tis better to have loved and
lost, n'est pas? Ngngyyahagah!"
The answers to all of these questions
could make for intriguing episodes;
ones we'll likely never get to see. And while
we can all live with a little mystery in the
year 3000, there's one lingering question, in
particular, that stands out as particularly
irksome. What is the Other, and why is
she so important to the universe's future?
We know who the Other is, of course. It's Leela.
That's revealed in the season four episode
The Why of Fry, which is arguably one of the
most important Futurama episodes ever made.
In it, Fry learns that the accident that landed
him in the cryogenic [kry-oh-JEN-ick] freezing
tube and sent him to the future
wasn't actually an accident at all.
It was part of a scheme by Nibbler, who spills
Futurama's big secret during the episode:
Fry isn't just a doofus. He's actually the
most important person in the entire universe.
See, because Fry is his own grandfather, the
former pizza delivery boy is immune to attacks
by the evil Brainspawn, making him the only person
who can stop their plans for galactic genocide.
In The Why of Fry, the Nibblonians give
Fry a Quantum Interphase Bomb and send
him off to fight the Brainspawn, where he
defeats them and saves the entire galaxy.
"Here we are, trapped for eternity."
"We could sing 'American Pie.'"
Unfortunately, there's a complication, as tends
to be the case with anything involving the Planet
Express crew, and Fry ends up back in 1999,
before he was frozen and sent to the future.
After some time-travel shenanigans, Fry goes back
to that fateful moment when he became stuck in
the cryogenic unit. It may seem like a retcon,
but if you go back to watch the Futurama pilot,
you'll see Nibbler's shadow
underneath where Fry sat,
showing how the creative team behind the
sitcom had their plan in place all along.
Back to Season 4, and Fry tries to stop Nibbler
from sending his original body to the year 3000.
Nibbler protests, however, arguing that
there must be something in the future that
Fry thinks is worth saving. That's where
the crucial piece of dialogue comes in.
"She must be the other."
"The wha?"
"You must not give up on her."
Fry doesn't know what that means… and we don't,
either. Sadly, it seems like we never will.
Fox canceled Futurama after its fourth season,
and while it came back from the dead two times,
the writers never bothered to explain
what Nibbler was talking about.
Given The Why of Fry's important place in
Futurama canon, Nibbler's words seem like
they carry a lot of weight — or they would,
if they were ever elaborated on. Of course,
in the absence of a real explanation,
fans have concocted their own theories.
Many assume that the Nibblonians have plans for
Leela that never made it to the screen. Meanwhile,
some think that Nibbler simply meant that Leela is
the second-most important person in the universe.
As that theory goes, Leela essentially saved
the galaxy by making Fry care. Ultimately,
Fry decides to send his past self to the future
in The Why of Fry because he loves Leela. As such,
she's indirectly responsible for all of Fry's
heroics. Fry is the one in the middle of things,
but Leela is the person who
gives Fry something to fight for.
Other fans suggest that Nibbler might be
referring to the series finale, in which Fry
and Leela live together as a couple for decades
while everyone else around them is stuck in
time. Maybe it's even a Star Wars reference
— Nibbler and Yoda have some similarities,
after all, although you've gotta hope that Fry
and Leela aren't secretly brother and sister.
Whatever the case, fan theories
are the only explanations as to
the Other's significance that we're
going to get. By all indications,
Futurama isn't ever coming back — making this
one big question that's bound to go unanswered.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.